Moi
أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس ينظرون إلى الهولا على أنها
مجرد نساء يرقصن ولكن أم نحن نحبها يا رجل ،
حولا هي
قصة تروي القصة بالطريقة
التي احتاجها سكان هاواي القدامى إلى وضع
نفسك في تلك الرقصة التي تحتاجها لتعيش
مثلهم  تحتاج إلى ترديد مثلهم ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى التدريب مثلهم
بشكل أساسي لتصبحهم ،
كما تعلم حتى أعرف مدى انخفاض مدرسة الهولا التي نؤديها في
جميع أنحاء العالم في
العصور القديمة ،
يتم تجنيد المحاربين بالفعل من
الجوف الذي يأتي الرئيس ليبحث عنه
تم اختيار صفوف الراقصين الذكور المتقدمين
ووريورز ،
ففلسفتنا الجوفاء هي نوع من تكرار ذلك
بالنسبة للرجل بولا الذي كان يروي
قصص المحارب والرقص مثل
المحارب ،
فأنت بحاجة إلى قطار مثل المحارب
[الموسيقى
] نتدرب في مكان خاص  قطعة أرض على
الجانب الغربي من أواهو باستخدام ما
يرأسه سكان هاواي القدامى فقط ، سواء كانت
صخور رمال المحيط عندما نأتي إلى
التدرب ، نتوقع أن نموت ،
إنها شاقة على الساقين ولكنها أيضًا
لتدريب عقلك.  أخبر نفسي
وبقية الأولاد إذا سقطت ، فذلك لأن
جسدي قد تخلى للتو عن
[الموسيقى]
كان من أصعب التدريبات التي نقوم
بها تسلق شجرة جوز الهند
أحيانًا تصل إلى القمة
ورجليك ترتجفان لأنك تعلم أنك
تحمل وزنك وتنظر إلى الأسفل
وأنت تعلم أنه ليس هناك ما يعيقك ، يجب أن تمتلك نوعًا ما عقلية المحارب هذه ، كما لو كنت تعلم أن هذا ما
أريد أن تعرفه ، سأحصل على هذه
[الموسيقى]
التي تعرفها عندما يأتي هؤلاء السادة إلى
حولا  إنهم مثل كرة من الصلصال
تبدو رائعة أكثر ، فأنا أنظر إليها على أنها
مسؤوليتي لتشكيلهم إلى
أفراد أفضل ، وآباء أفضل ، وأبناء
أفضل ، وأبناء أفضل ، وهدفنا هو أنه عندما
ينتهي هؤلاء الرجال من الرقص ، فإنهم
يتركون هنا أشخاصًا أفضل.
بالنسبة لي ثقافيًا ،
لا يزال الأمر يعيدني إلى هاواي ، حيث كان
الناس يفقدون أحيانًا أن الوها
لبعضهم البعض وأن الحب لبعضهم
البعض والهولا يمنحك هذا
الرجل
الذي أرقص في الواقع حتى تسقط ركبتي
وحتى بعد ذلك ، سأفعل
كل ما بوسعي من أجل الجوف ،
كما تعلمون لدينا هذه الأخوية حيث
نعتني ببعضنا البعض ، نحن نساعد في دفع
بعضنا البعض ، إنه شغفي وأنا
أتطلع إلى رؤية أين تأخذني الهولا في
حياتك